so haben sie gut geschlafen
super ich tue ihnen auch der rote wäsche
ich das gut
wir werden alle immer älter und es gibt
immer weniger menschen wie heiko schulz
die uns im alter pflegen und betreuen
wollen
ich denke dass ich sehr viel aus dem
beruf aufnehmen kann für mich selber wie
man auch vielleicht mit dem leben
umgehen sollte
und das eben vielleicht auch nicht alles
gutes im leben dass man sich auch auf
seiten mal einstellen sollte wohin
vielleicht auch nicht alles so klappt
[Musik]
und es natürlich auch ein schönes gefühl
wenn man jemand helfen können
[Musik]
und heute sogar schönes wetter schön
sonne scheint
michael schulz pflegefachmann mit
herzblut wieso macht ihn seine arbeit
glücklich und warum hängen andererseits
so viele pflegende ihren beruf an den
nagel
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
pflegefachmann heiko schulz arbeitsort
ist eine demenzabteilung im
pflegezentrum embrach die pflege von
dementen ist anspruchsvoll ihre
bedürfnisse und allfällige schmerzen
können diese menschen kaum mehr äußern
rahman morgen kreiert sie ja frau meier
ich du nochmal zu decken die beine
einfach dass sie sich nicht erschrecken
so bis sperrte frau meier ist jetzt das
dritte mal
aber auch das dritte mal dass sie
angefangen zu lächeln und das ist genau
das warum ich das eigentlich gemacht
weil ich weiß mit zwei minuten
investition fühlt sie sich sicher
fröhlich und denkt dass uns so das nennt
man bei uns so diese rhetorik
ritualisierten begegnung und damit kann
man sehr sehr viel sicherheit vermitteln
heute morgen müssen sie mal auf toilette
und yahoo hätten hätte ich ihn jetzt
gerade
ich gehe schon ins badezimmer und
schulsachen vorbereiten und nicht
erzählt es noch beispiel zufrieden
ich muss sagen ich habe mich so daran
gewöhnt auch mit der zeit jetzt ist
speziell ich habe auch noch ein bisschen
heuschnupfen basiswissen zu der merkt
dass wir ganz so aber es ist wirklich
man gewöhnt sich dran oder und mit den
jahren macht einen das eigentlich oder
mir persönlich nichts mehr aus jeder
fahrer also wenn ich weiß wo von den
kollegen der einer kann vielleicht
weniger stuhlgang riechen dann hat
extrem mühe wenn jemand verbrauchen hat
also das auch noch mit unterschiedlicher
oder aber ich kann oder ich würde fast
sagen der jahrelang so ein bisschen im
altersbereich geschafft hat der hat
schon eine menge gebrochen
herr wollen sich hippe läutet sie herr
ruft können sie da auch sehr häufig du
schnell baute raus ich komme gleich
sie sage den kunst und das ist immer
wertschätzung auch er kann sich so immer
wieder besser orientieren er weiß ganz
genau erst angesprochen auf das auch so
dass die menschen mit einer demenz
einfach die konzentration nicht mehr so
haben sie gucken in den raum und
verlieren sich denn schon in der
tätigkeit dieser 1 gemacht haben würden
dann gerade wieder irgendwas anderes
machen
demenzkranke menschen leben in ihrer
eigenen welt die arbeit mit ihnen liest
ein ständiges erahnen von bedürfnissen
und der vielen von grenzen man kann es
bei den menschen merken die jetzt in der
demenz noch nicht ganz soweit sind da
merkt man oft auch dass sie sich schämen
oder das schamgefühl sehr stark
ausgeprägt ist und das ist ein sehr
sensibles thema wo man wirklich auch
sehr behutsam mit umgehen muss und auch
sich wie hat mir so langsam rantasten
wann ist wirklich hilfe auch gewollt
dass es so glaube ich der schlüsselpunkt
und später ist aber auch so mit der
erkrankung dass das schamgefühl was wir
jetzt haben dass das kart bei der demenz
auch in vielen situationen auch
verschwindet und dass die leute an sich
in dem moment nicht das schamgefühl
vielleicht jetzt so grad wahrnehmen
sondern er vielleicht die hilflosigkeit
oder ein ganz anderer wunsch eben das
bedürfnis hunger zu haben
wir haben auch leute die achten nicht
darauf ob sie etwas anhaben aber wenn
sie hunger haben gehen sie zum beispiel
zurück dann interessiert sie nicht
ob jetzt jemanden sie nackt sehen würde
zb der mangel an diplomierten
pflegepersonal ist dramatisch es werden
zu wenig pflegende ausgebildet zu viele
steigen aus oder arbeiten nur noch
teilzeit
fast ein drittel der fachkräfte kommt
heute aus dem ausland das jahr zur
massen einwanderungs initiative wird die
situation noch verschärfen
auch hier im zürcherischen embrach
kämpft man seit jahren gegen den
fachkräftemangel insbesondere dass wir
uns besonders mit 101 polte wirklich
attraktive arbeitsbedingungen
arbeitsteam oder gutti
fortbildungsmöglichkeiten dass jeder
arbeitsplatz wirklich in sich attraktiv
ist dass wir sehr viel investieren
noch sehr viel mythos bildet und dann
probiere dir natürlich bio ist bolte und
es mir extrem verärgert für wort ccs
fachpersonal und woche wieder anders
personalisierten jetzt dann gleich noch
die hose 14 ja nicht verschließen
beispielsweise können zwar auch laien
die kunst der pflege besteht aber oft
gerade darin gewisse dinge nicht zu tun
man kann viel übernehmen und für den
moment scheint das wirklich der
vielleicht auch schneller zu gehen aber
wenn man ein bisschen weitsicht hat
erkennt man umso mehr man wirklich macht
und umso weniger die lüth selber machen
um so schneller gehen wirklich die
fähigkeiten und ressourcen verloren und
später muss man es denn so oder so
übernehmen suchmaschinen
man muss geduld mitbringen ich sage ganz
ehrlich wenn man in dem beruf schafft
und geduld hat dann wird man mit der
zeit unglücklich leute sie können sich
da gerade 17
ich helfe ihnen jetzt mal bei move
pflegefachleute wie heiko schulz planen
koordinieren und überprüfen die pflege
in heimen spitälern oder bei der spitex
die erhaltung der motorischen
fähigkeiten mit einem spaziergang gehört
hier genauso dazu wie das lindern von
schmerzen oder gespräche mit angehörigen
die geistigen emotionalen und sozialen
fähigkeiten werden im zusätzlichen
aktivierungs therapien gefördert und
erholt
das sieht der erste
[Musik]
ich kann nur erahnen wie schmerz auf
design muss erinnerungen verblassen die
eigenen fähigkeiten schwinden zu sehen
schwermut die bekommt mich beim gedanken
vielleicht der einst selber in solch
einer institution zu ändern
die angestellten hier denken pragmatisch
ich würde natürlich am liebsten 100 und
gesund und zu hause leben aber das leben
sieht meistens anders aus als man sich
das so vorstellt und wichtig ist glaube
einfach dass man unterstützung erhält
das man begleitet wird dass man menschen
um sich herum hat sich noch für einen
interessieren die lebend auf dem weg
begleiten ob der weg jetzt schwieriger
ist oder weniger schwierig aber kein
mensch möchte alleine sein
machen sie das meiste beim meister
cancellara darfst rabatt
mit der zeit hat man gewisse wahrnehmung
wo man bedürfnisse russischen jetzt
bewohnern kann sich nicht mehr so
verbalisieren unsere informationen geben
und dann versucht man das auch nicht
unbedingt zu sage ich mal
herauszufordern
dann versucht man einfach in ihrer
sprache sowie sie spricht versucht man
mit diesen worten oder manchmal sind es
nur so trocken dass man dort mit geht
und dass der bewohner sich dann trotzdem
ernst genommen fühlt können sich dort
[Musik]
können sie dann zum bett laufe ja ich
weiß nicht wann sie es probieren wollen
sich einmal alle sitze ja bezieht kann
sich da gerade alle sitze ja nur langsam
genau
seine mittagspause verbringt drei kos
meistens alleine
sind sehr sehr gefordert bei uns jetzt
auf der station wo ich arbeite sind wir
auch denke ich gefordert von der
kreativität oder wir müssen immer wieder
sachen ausprobiere in der kommunikation
wir müssen uns immer wieder auf neue
situationen einstellen
man kann nicht so ein plan haben und
dann wird er wirklich so erfüllt man
muss flexibel sein und dieses ganze
drumherum auch was auch passiert auf der
station oder das ist man immer sehr
gespannt und mit seinem sinn dabei und
das kostet kraft das kostet kraft weil
immer präsent sein muss jetzt nicht
schnell und es gibt es aggressionen
dazu will jemand ein zimmer von jemand
anderem
ich merke jetzt glaube ich lag dass das
nicht mehr vorkommt könnte man sich
aufreger ein kleines wetters gerangel
und bewohnerinnen handfester können
aggressionen gegenüber den fliegenden
ausfallen
und wenn man beschimpft wird wenn man
gefragt wird das sind so sachen die
machen uns leid weniger es aber sollten
eigentlich immer noch trotzdem ernst
genommen werden aber es kann dann
wirklich bis führen zum schlagen
getreten werden bissverletzungen haben
wir sogar schon gehabt und was mir
persönlich ist avisiert wurde ich wurde
angespuckt und das ziemlich nahe
mundbereich und farbe grad die
nackenhaare vitro das ist etwas was man
natürlich nicht gerne haben möchte oder
man kommt auch menge an grenzen
das benutzen wir eigentlich
hauptsächlich für bewohner die nicht
mehr alleine stehen können hier aber in
der speziellen situation nicht
vorbereitet benutzen wir das auch um
die sicherheit zu gewährleisten haben
bewohner der öfters auch aggressiv
reagiert und das genau das problem dass
er zum beispiel in einem moment das
gleichgewicht verliert und mit stark an
wie ein hebel wollen aber er in dem
moment wenn duell uns dann den arm beißt
oder uns box ja darum dass noch kopf auf
und deswegen benutzen wir das in dieser
situation um für ihn und für uns die
sicherheit zu gewährleisten
da ich noch was zu drehen für sie sind
die zehnte der macht gut sondern auch
feststellen rechte wahr
da freue ich mich auch immer wenn sie
mich anlächelt herauf ja wir verstehen
uns gut
tschuldigung sie können mit kommen da
uns beziehen 3q schutzschicht neigt sich
dem ende zu aber aufpassen dass ich weiß
noch dass sein körper doch ausgerechnet
jetzt einmal in einem patientenzimmer
vorsichtig
ja ich kann dir so schnelles boot sein
willst musst dich besiegt auch jetzt
bewohnerinnen hat steuer gehabt und hat
es nicht adäquat versorgen können jetzt
das volle der boote voll festivals nach
stimmt alles das interieur ist auch eine
etwas der licht so schönen moment in
unserem job
wie gehen sie mit dem ja ich man gewöhnt
sich zwar daran mit der zeit aber es
musste unbedingt sei das war passt nun
wieder erlebt vorsichtig das könnte
jetzt sage ich freue mich weiter an zu
haben
aber es ist auch ein bisschen gemein
aber ich helfe jetzt trotzdem noch
schnell ich gehe auch wenn der wohne ein
dass vielleicht leben um endlich zeigen
kann
aber man weiß trotzdem was man gemacht
hat und man weiß dass man jemand anderen
geholfen hat und ich denke das ist immer
noch etwas sehr schönes
was vielleicht heutzutage auch in der
gesellschaft vielleicht eben manchmal
auch ein bisschen zu kurz kommt eines
tages werden wir aufwachen und wissen
dass wir zu wenig getan haben oder das
falsche auftritt bis drei coaches
freundin nach ihre berufslehre zur
fachfrau gesundheit hat sie eine
schauspielausbildung absolviert heute
arbeitet sie nur noch mit einem 20
prozent pensum in der pflege
drei codes ist 34 jahre alt seiner
älteren schwester christina ist er vor
zwölf jahren von der insel usedom in die
schweiz gefolgt
ich habe meine ausbildung abgeschlossen
also ich hatte einen der steine in
berlin
und gleichzeitig haben sich um die
kollegen uns zusammen der schweiz
beworben über so eine
vermittlungsagentur ja und die haben uns
dann die haben recht schnell kontakt mit
uns aufgenommen haben sich auch sehr gut
haben gefragt wo wir arbeiten wollen
es hat einfach damals gestimmt christina
und heiko schulz begeisterung über ihre
arbeit ist bis heute ungebrochen
und es ist das austritt bühne gegangen
die berüchtigten teufelskreis von
personalknappheit überlastungen der
schöpfung laute sie auch halt einfach
immer das schnell schnell grad mit
dementen bewohner gott sagt einfach
damit schnell und dann halt einfach der
clean schummer hätten dennoch alles gut
dokumentieren und sollten halt einfach
so erinnere kreis zeit wo es gibt und
dass man halt einfach nicht verlust hat
jetzt noch zu deinem bewohners konsum
ich kann sie sehr sehr gut verstehen und
ich denke es ist ja auch ein bisschen
typ abhängig und jeder macht so seine
eigenen erfahrungen auch noch eine
pflege das sagt ja man kann nicht immer
alles so vergleichen oder
pauschalisieren mit weniger niedrig
prozent der hund stoffen viel mehr
energie und traf diene und und dann geht
das gut
da bietet wenn ich das mystery oder 16
ist einfach unbefriedigend für mich
selber warum
es ist 23 uhr im pflegezentrum embrach
drei kurs startet seine nachtschicht wie
immer mit einem rundgang durch alle
zimmer doch mittendrin ein notruf aus
einer anderen abteilung bisher um kate
ja wir versuchen gleich zu helfen hat
machen uns erstmal ein bisschen platz
kann man dann von hinten dran highlights
an den bei und du kommst am besten musik
es sieht uns als bedrohung an
ganz kurz das sind erst mal ganz kurz
beruhigen
das recht zu werben hat sich auf sitzt
können sie mal auf sie zu
versuchen sie mal auf sie zu also sehr
gut gut du wenn du auch mal später ist
ruft sonst noch mal ran
so wie es jetzt vom ersten eindruck
erstmal ist hat er sich nicht verletzt
ich denke es das einfach für ihn sehr
schockierend gewesen
der este nacht verläuft ruhig da bleibt
endlich genug zeit für die dokumentation
der pflege maßnahmen bei tagesanbruch um
auf sex macht sich unruhe breit bis zum
7 ist drei coaches allein auf der
station mit den 17 gewonnen
jetzt sind zwei klingeln und ich muss
jetzt entscheiden aber da sie
sturzgefährdet ist gehe ich natürlich
gleich zu ihr und muss dann erst nachher
zusammenwohnen
[Musik]
ja es muss ich ein bisschen passieren da
die bewohner nicht so viel geduld hat
zum worte und nicht dass sie allein auf
stadt hat sich nach helfen kann
so mussten sie lange war darauf michael
schulz wieder passiert ja genau das
jetzt so ein bisschen rasch aber jetzt
zurück und schauen dass man möglichst
überall an jedem ort ist wiewohl sie
nochmal zu decken
der weg ins pflegeheim ist wie eine
einbahnstraße wüsste ich mein lebensende
hier verbringen
ich würde mir menschen wie heiko schulz
an meiner seite wünschen ganz gut habe
die nacht gut verbracht
diese fielen blieb ohne happy-end wäre
da nicht drei codes mit seiner liebe zum
beruf und den menschen die er betreut
happy end für mich zum beispiel wenn
jemand im sterben liegt und er hat keine
schmerzen er wird gut betreut die
angehörigen werden gut betreut
man schaut und macht was man kann das
ist für mich auch ein happyend uns ist
vielleicht auch ein happy end vom labour
oder wenn man wie gesagt ohne schmerzen
gehen kann und mit der einbahnstraße ist
halt immer so eine sache ich finde auch
auf der letzten fahrt sollte man möglich
auch gut betreut werden und man freut
sich immer über einen freundlichen
schaffen
[Musik]